if you can find a way to restore my
energy i may just let you two leave this
place
all right let's restore his energy dude
[Music]
what is this
oh my gosh what is happening
hold on i gotta i feel like we gotta
take away the face campers
[Music]
i can't say i saw this coming guys
[Music]
i can't say
that i saw this coming
[Music]
so if this is your first time joining us
welcome
to retro racket tour live we do this
thing every monday wednesday
usually fridays too but right now i'm
getting back into work
still trying to keep the stream going
still trying to keep the youtube going
so
tonight we are jumping into paper mario
the origami king for the very first time
isn't this great bro back on the road
again together and heading to some kind
of festival
here we are toad town and there's
peach's castle
dude i just want to hang out in toad
town forget the castle
this little town looks awesome oh man i
can do a pretty good mario impression i
don't know that i could keep it up to
the whole
like the whole sentence let's go
hold on let me back up for this one
super mario
galaxy see
not bad right
yes okay we are in control now guys
you're in control oh this is weird this
is
weird this flat 2d mario
moving around in a 3d space
okay music's a little strange right here
how good to see you what has happened
what's going on with her i see
last question will you
crease yourself and be reborn like me
will i crease myself
uh no again we're gonna say no on that
goodbye what okay no she's under some
kind of spell
she is 100 under some kind of spell i
don't like this
mario 1 000
fold arms
that sounded good are your arms all big
and foldy now
i've heard about this i think those are
called 1000 fold arms
okay try feeling around a bit maybe you
can help me escape
from this strange dimension
it feels like the arms are off center
and out of control maybe try pressing r
to reset them
oh if it feels okay oh it's like motion
control all right
whoa oh look like a little fox at first
oh my goodness or mario and bows are
going to get to work together i'm
here for this i am totally in for this
let's go
peach what are you why haven't you
joined me in
folded glory interesting so if we use
the hammer look
see the red space over there it looks
like the hammer would hit
in kind of a four tile pattern
going left to right whereas this will
hit four tiles
back to back to back to back all right
so let's hit boots
start battle mario's turn so it is it is
turn based
oh if i press a while he's jumping it
does a little like extra jump
i guess that's why this is called a wave
battle if you see last wave pop up that
means you're on the last group
if you see last wave pop up
it means you're on the last group whoa
look at this
i'm telling you dude like the artist for
these games
oh it just automatically picks it up
love it when games do that
love it when games do that i have a
feeling you've collected enough confetti
by now
maybe try heading over to the hole very
carefully
all right
i think your back is filled to the room
with the confetti already
okay just let i mean i'm walking that
way
okay that doesn't look like that would
be enough
that looks
okay there we go all right and we got
some coins for doing it
did it work it sounds like it worked
well if it worked this one time it
should work every time you find one of
these call me optimistic
yeah we got this and the last one will
be a heart which we don't really need
but we'll happily take it
nailed it oh and a star
hey get back here get back here
wait what what's the point of this oh i
know what the point of it is
oh how do i get up here
right here
come on come on come on yes we made it
mario
barely but we did number one a
collectible treasure kind of like little
trophies i guess
peach's castle
all right now i've been waiting to see
i'm anxious to see what's inside here
it's just gonna be coins
oh it broke
ah okay and you use the 1 000
folded arms
oh just confetti okay good
i was like there better be something
else in there
a shriveled seed a seed that seems to be
shriveled for lack
of water you can't sit on old grand
sappy's head mister
that's right he's the elder of this
forest show some respect he's got
twigs older than you
so what if he's been logged by those
nasty little toads he's still the man
honey
oh my goodness oh there he is
yes yes thank you darlings
bless your bark
you young man go back and tell your flat
paper friends what a state i'm in
i've oddly the hardwoods to speak let
alone learn
you some manners
oh it's the trees the trees were all
talking whispering as we were walking
through here guys
old grand sappy here hasn't been the
same since they cut him down
that's why he's mad at y'all flat paper
folks cutting down
good trees in their prime shame on you
oh and by the way you need grand sappers
permission if you ever plan on leaving
hon
so now that you're here better get comfy
cause you're gonna be here forever
okay grand sappy what do you need from
us
we will help you sir um mr grand sappy
we're not with those flat paper people
who did this to you
we are not and actually i'm not even
flat paper i'm origami
origami you say my eyes aren't what they
used to be
well if what you say is true then
perhaps you may be of some assistance to
me
if you can find a way to restore my
energy i may just let you two leave this
place
all right let's restore his energy dude
that's so wonderfully generous of you
truly i only wish we knew how to restore
your energy
anyway we're in a hurry ourselves so
we'll do our best to help
i guess if you're gonna help grand savvy
we'll let you wander around a bit
yeah you best let me wander around
stop talking to me
you press a just as you land on an enemy
you'll deal more damage i thought i
remembered that from past
paper mario game
we got the three twelves messed up the
first one then after that we got the
hang of it
yes a perfectly lined up jump attack is
so satisfying
hey this is that spring that we saw
before
i feel calmer somehow just standing near
it
normally i would suggest this but do you
think we should try throwing something
in there
i'm gonna throw i'm gonna do the
shriveled seed
the shriveled seed into the water
[Music]
see i brought my snacks in here tonight
guys
what is it a soul seed yo that's what
old grand sappy needed
tonight we've got some nutter butter
bites
these things are so good but it's like
because they're bite-sized you can just
eat
a ton of them before you realize it
so i'm gonna take two seal it back up
and put it down
so we try not to think about it
all right let's see can we close oh
somebody doesn't like this
oh he knows okay
he's hurt uh oh yeah i wanna i wanna do
these two as well
we'll get to you grand sappy don't worry
we'll get to you don't panic
all right another mushroom
yeah what is this going to do man boost
our attack or something
give us fire abilities what's it going
to be
use this to throw fireballs at enemies
in a straight line
all right we gotta get back to grand
sappy guys
we gotta get back to him i feel like
something bad is happening to him
look at all the trees they're panicking
no time to stop and whack the flowers
hurry hurry can't handle more drama do
you guys have enough time for me to stop
and save though i hope so
because that's how we roll we save and
we save a lot
run mario run
what did they do to him
they ripped him out of the world
oh they are gonna be ticked at me
is the shallow himself hollowed out like
some woodshop project gone wrong
okay can we fix him with confetti can we
i can't believe those horrible things
ganged up on old grand sappy and did
this too
they they deserve to be chipped
we'll take care of it don't worry this
doesn't look good he was already creaky
now he's downright hollowed out
oh man
all right here he is guys closely at his
face doesn't look like one of those
whole
yes it does maybe that means you can fix
him with confetti
we're gonna try we're gonna try this you
guys ready for this boom
i mean the confetti does come from the
trees anyway
so the trees are are restoring
old grand seven all right here he goes
yes there he is
we brought him back
oh what happened felt like some rap
scallion was whittling me down again
did i just dream it no it was actually
totally real
i suppose that's just the memory of
going downhill
oh nuts grandsap is back y'all oh wait
that's the wrong voice
let's see mustache check creepy eyeballs
check it's grand savvy again all right
thank you he's still a shell of himself
but it's better than being a shell of a
shell
we've got our precious elder back
he's not hollow anymore yeah we need to
give him the seed now let's give him the
seed
the soul seed i hope he just like grows
massively
come on dude come on dude wait wait how
do i
just go talk to him
yes we've got the soul seed for you sir
here it is
enjoy come on come on
sprout your trunk your leaves
show us who you really are grand sappy
[Music]
what is this
oh my gosh what is happening
hold on i gotta i feel like we gotta
take away the face campers
[Music]
i can't say i saw this coming guys
[Music]
i can't say
[Music]
that i saw this coming
oh they should have just left it there
dude could you imagine of all that and
it's just like this tiny little sprout
and that's it wow i was not expecting
that
oh my goodness neither was i
looking good grand sappy i'm so happy
for you
yeah now that's what i'm talking about
that little seed was all it took
tightened up my timbers and put the funk
back in my trunk
i'm young again i see no need to keep
y'all waiting any longer unless you want
to
run through that song and dance again
shrubs
open up for my main mustache and his
little lady here
yeah onward we go
onward great now we can
keep making it on our way or making our
way back to beach's castle
let's get a move on mario i'm still
pretty worried about your green
family bye for now grand sappy i'm glad
we could be of service
yeah yeah yeah goodbye
keep out unless you want to stay forever
wait so you're saying keep out of
there where we just were yeah they made
me out of one of grand sappy's branches
reduce reuse recycle i guess
oh man
is that toad oh my goodness oh what's
that
some kind of face head hat thing is
stuck in that shrub
come on we know who that is i've got a
bad feeling no i've got a good feeling
it's toad let's get him let's get him
wait that's what a toad looks like wow i
was way off
that's because my face is all folded up
please help me please help me
we got you toad we got you i don't care
what it takes hammer me out of the shrub
if you have to
can i just pull him out oh okay i guess
we yep literally have to hammer him out
that's marginally better
now just need some flattening out i
think okay we need to hammer you again
oh my gosh this game you guys i don't
mean to be rude too but i have to ask
how did your face end up so
bent and wonky oh it's bad
real bad these horrible folda guys
showed up and started folding toads up
left and right
most of us got folded before we could
even ask what was going on
what do they have against toads it's not
fair toads have rights this is toad
abuse
i just re-traumatized myself right
the humor oh my gosh i know we've got a
few other things on our plate but you'll
help any toads you find once you marry
of course we're gonna help the toads
toads are like my favorite mario
character i heard that and i'm
holding you to that affirmative gesture
mario
but us toads can help you too if you
press y during battle we'll come
cheer you on the more of us you have
cheering the more help we can give you
good things will happen i promise well
can i just like spam it i mean
oh we will try there you i know yeah you
see there you go
there you go you knew there's gonna be a
cost associated
we will charge you a modest fee for the
cheering should have mentioned that you
should have towed but it's okay we knew
anyway because we're gamers
that toad is a shrewd one but it sounds
like it could be a big help to have them
cheer us on in battle don't you think
love the music already in this game are
you serious i'm gonna have to do it
again
[Music]
i guess they i'm guessing that you pay
them with coins
anybody home anybody here
anybody here oh there's a little goomba
over there look at him look at him look
at him
turn around dude turn around are we
ready for you
battle time oh i forgot see
oh yikes i don't like this oh
okay okay okay timing
oh yeah there we go that's it right
there that is definitely the one
use our hammer on these guys right here
oh we got the perfect timing now on
these dudes we're gonna use the boots
oh we got all 12 12 on every one of them
puzzle completion bonus no damage bonus
285
coins to mario
[Music]
oh look at this little swing
[Music]
what is that what
oh another toad i was waiting for the
swing but then that weird goomba cut in
line there you go toad have fun on the
swing dude
all right let's fill this up right here
and fill this up just a wee okay
apparently a wee bit more
and apparently a wee bit more
and we're good now okay okay that took
way more than i expected it to take
lots of coins all right we're starting
to run low and confetti need to run back
and
oh i'm glad we went back because i did
not think that would happen
oh now i'm sad i don't want the music to
stop i thought we were gonna like get
that item or something
i thought it was in a port an important
item when in reality it was just
now we're cutting off the music now jeez
i didn't mean to do that can i put it
back up there
i like that music i like that little
vibe we had going
photo mode photo mode anybody
finally a minute to rest oh
it heals him didn't know that
that's good okay so we saved the
mushroom i'm glad we saved it because
there was really
we don't we only got hit just a little
bit
oh here's another one you guys
okay we gotta pull him
yeah toad we got you i don't know why i
was trying to cut more firewood like
that i have plenty
oh there's another one of those little
one of those little dudes right there
another little toad
why is the toad like a little bug it
looks like a little bug up in the tree
what if i talk to this one i'll never
take peace and quiet for granted again i
should probably retire from my job as a
school teacher
wait check what is this we used to be
trees but don't feel bad for us we'll
turn into ashes and grow again
oh wow one day i'll burn
light me we must burn what
oh my gosh this feels so wrong
this feels so wrong
[Music]
okay so you do get like a special early
[Music]
hit
all right i need to move you there
and move you there look at that dude
this i really i mean this is gonna get
the more it goes i can see this getting
really advanced think about all the
possible combinations they could they
could set up with this
all right see if we can time that hammer
right again
yeah there we go
[Music]
battle bonus complete any sign of
of fire because those guys
those logs over there it sounds like
they they want us to light them on fire
look at him look at him over here dude
one day i'll burn we must burn
light me what oh wait we do have that
item
oh but i guess you can only use that in
battle
wait where'd it go there it is the fire
flower
yeah it's like it's grayed out i guess
you have to unlock something or
maybe it's one of those things you can
only use in battle is that another toad
in there
oh my goodness they're everywhere guys
they're everywhere
thanks for saving me from that wood pile
but these creases are so deep will i
go back to normal you want me to hit you
two
like the other toad maybe i could pick
up a side gig as an accordion
completely unrelated
oh why do you think that little
side patch is a different color thank
you toad
okay can we repair that looks like we
can from right here
there's a lot to repair though over here
a lot to repair
[Music]
oh no oh no
oh no stop stop talking to me let me i
need to get up there
those coins are going to vanish i don't
want them to vanish
there we go
[Music]
and then we can also get over here i
just saw
[Music]
oh there's another one maybe this is the
dude that lived here
[Music]
are you the one that lived in the house
it was so lonely back here with no one
to talk to i had to come up with an
imaginary friend
she's actually pretty cool do you want
to hear all about her oh yeah i guess
you can press
x to get a hint from your real friend
whenever you want so you wouldn't
understand
are you the one who lives here dude are
you are you the one
other than what seemed to be the proper
thing uh to light that little area on
fire
firing it up so you can wolf it down
welcome to toad's barbecue food eatery
all firewood is happy to burn
yet again though we don't have any way
of burning it yet
that i know of uh it was nice getting
into paper mario so
initial thoughts on paper mario that
origami king definitely starts a little
slow
the game holds your hand a lot a lot a
lot a lot it holds your hand
and i feel like that would be nice for
kids but also there's a lot of
reading in there there's a lot of
reading so for really young kids
hold on pico so for really young kids i
don't know how that would
i don't know how that would uh go down
you know i appreciate you guys hanging
out here tonight and i hope you all have
a fantastic
rest of your week i'll talk to you again
soon